- Heidi Klum and Winnie Harlow!
Give it up!
(audience cheering)
In honor of their show, "Making the Cut,"
it is time for a little pop quiz
called Making the Cut, But with What?
♪ Making the cut, but with what ♪
- (laughing) I love that music.
That was awesome, I'm just
gonna do this the whole time.
Winnie's been kind enough to host
as Heidi and I battle it out
with our COVID safe distance
cool, super cool hands.
So Winnie, will you explain the game
while I look fabulous doing this?
- Yes, of course.
So in this game, I'll ask
a series of questions.
The answer to each question
is something that cuts.
Anything from chef's knives
to "Edward Scissorhands."
The first person to hit the buzzer
and give the right answer gets the point.
- Okay.
- [Heidi] Ready.
- But steals are allowed.
If Kelly wins,
the right side of the
audience gets a cool prize.
And if Heidi wins, it's the left side.
And her photo goes up
on the Blake Shelton Wall of Champions,
which have beat Kelly Clarkson.
- I hate that wall.
That wall sucks.
(laughing)
That's a stupid wall, Heidi.
That's a stupid wall.
- All right, guys, here
we go, first question.
What cutting device
was famously part of a massacre in Texas?
- Chainsaw!
(squealing)
(ringing)
- Oh, oh, my gosh!
(clapping)
I went like, I didn't go movies.
I went like real things.
- [Winnie] I would not have
gotten that one either.
- I was like, aw, that was horrible.
I am a loser.
Nicely done, Klum.
- So Heidi gets that point.
- I wanna win.
- I love how competitive you are.
I am feeling the energy, okay.
- All right, here's the next one.
What cutting device might you see
going back and forth in
someone's front of house?
- Lawnmower!
(whacking)
- What.
(dinging)
A what.
- [Winnie] A what.
- A la, a lawnmower.
- [Winnie] A lawnmower.
- I was like, what did you,
did you say a land mower?
- [Winnie] I'm so happy I'm
not playing this game because.
(laughing)
- Oh, my God!
You're gonna get your picture on the wall.
Just for land mower,
you're going on the wall.
- Come on, Kelly, you gotta catch up!
- [Kelly] I, honestly,
I don't know what's-
- Next question!
- [Winnie] Here is the next one.
- Ah, ga.
- In the news, what was
the cutting machine called
that you would chop, that
would chop off your head?
That's so scary.
(dinging)
- Oh, wait.
- Guillotine!
(banging)
- Uh.
- Has she seen the answers or something?
- How come it doesn't ring now?
- Do you notice that
I'm hitting the button
and my glove, it doesn't light up?
Does anyone else notice that?
Is this rigged?
(laughing)
- I'm going straight to the live show.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- The competition is hot
right here right now.
(laughing)
- [Heidi] Next question!
- All right, next question.
What is the name of the long curved blade
that Death is seen carrying?
(dinging)
- A seeth, a scythe.
Yes!
- [Winnie] We got a point, yeah.
- You didn't even wanna
work when I hit you?
- I don't even know, what is?
- [Winnie] I don't even
know how to pronounce that.
- Sith, sith, scythe?
- Scythe?
- That's not in my vocabulary.
I don't know.
- Yeah, yeah, I got it, yep?
Got one.
- Okay, so now it's two behind, okay.
- Okay, Heidi three, Kelly one.
- I know, I know!
- Here's the next one.
For all of you "Game of Thrones" fans.
- [Heidi] Oh, no, I didn't watch that.
- Yeah, I did!
- Which characters use
swords called ice blades?
- I don't know.
- Oh, well I don't remember.
I'm not that nerdy.
- I don't know.
- [Winnie] Come on
guys, who's the villain?
- I don't know, I don't know.
- Oh, the walkie.
No, no, the, the, the, the, the, the.
- [Winnie] Come on, come on, come on.
- The, the, they're not alive.
They're the white people.
- Yes, you said both!
- The, the, the, the, the, the.
Oh, my God, I know who they are!
I can't, the White Walkers!
(dinging)
Yes!
(clapping)
- Ooh, ya gainin' on Heidi!
- [Kelly] I'm gaining.
- I didn't know that
because I didn't watch it.
- It turns out I am that nerdy.
- All right, here is the next one.
- Now I'm sad.
- Okay, shoot.
- Come on, we all got this one.
- [Heidi] Okay, what is it?
- Oh, don't shame me already.
- No, no, we got this, we got this.
- Okay.
- When you're getting a manicure,
what cutting tool are they likely to use?
(banging)
- Nail clippers.
(dinging)
Scissors.
- [Kelly] What.
- Clippers, nail clippers.
- Yep, yep.
- Oh, man.
- Got it.
- Aw man, hey Chris?
Hey Chris, you don't need to hold up the,
we know that I'm losing, okay?
You don't need to hold up
your fingers four to two.
That's just rude.
(laughing)
- Here is the next one.
Which superhero played by Ryan Reynolds
walks around with a pair of Katana swords?
(banging)
- "Deadpool!"
(ringing)
(screaming)
Bam.
- That's one of my favorite superheroes.
- Oh, my God, it's amazing.
Even "Deadpool 2."
Sequels usually suck.
Not that one.
- [Winnie] Incredible, it was so good.
- Yeah, way to go Ryan Reynolds.
- All right, so here we go for three.
Here's the next one.
- Okay.
- This precious gem is
so hard that it can-
- Diamond!
(dinging)
(screaming)
It's my birthstone.
That's what I'm talking about.
- [Audience Member] It's tied.
- [Kelly] It's tied?
- [Audience Member] We need a tiebreaker!
- Shoot, it's a tiebreaker.
- How many more questions?
- This is the tiebreaker,
one more, one more.
- Only one more?
- Oh, my gosh, oh, my gosh.
Okay, okay.
- Kelly.
- What cutting tool is also
the name of a type of puzzle?
- A jig?
No, I don't know.
(banging)
- Jigsaw!
(dinging)
(groaning)
- All right, guys.
With five points, Heidi is the winner!
(congratulatory music)
- What just happened?
I'm tired (laughing), damnit.
Oh, thanks for playing,
Heidi, congratulations.
- So now what happens now?
- So you get to go on the wall.
- Whoo!
- Yeah, it's so exciting.
That also means that all the people
on the left side, y'all won.
So, and it's my show
and I don't want you to go home a loser,
so everyone makes the cut today.
So let's give everyone the prize.
The Nama Cold Press juicer
is one of the strongest
juicers on the market
with up to 60% more juice.
The Nama is engineered
to provide more nutrients
and better flavor.
It has multiple functions
so you can make almond milk, which I love.
Oat milk and even sorbets.
Plus, it's kid safe and
super easy to clean,
which all you mamas,
you're gonna love that.
You're all getting a
chance to start juicing
because everyone in our house seats
is getting a Nama juicer.
Nam, nam, nam, nam, nam.
- [Winnie] Us too?
- Yes.
(laughing)
- [Heidi] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Not Heidi.
'Cause she beat me.
Jig, I just said jig.
Why did I say just jig?
I don't know why I did that, I don't know.
- I've been dying to do this.
- I don't know, but it
helped me get to it.
(ringing)
- Bam.
- Well, you did better than me.
The button wouldn't work
the first few times.
Okay, and since Heidi won,
following the show her
photo will be mounted
on the Blake Shelton Wall of Champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
It's so great, I'm excited for you.
A big hand for Heidi Klum
and Winnie Harlow, everybody.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- That was awesome,
and I love your energy.
"Making the Cut" premieres
on Amazon Prime Video on July 16th.
Y'all gotta check it out.